tout le monde qui a un bébé
reçoit un million de dollars et c'est un génie de 132
iq
qui est littéralement allé à l'
hôpital parce que son cerveau
était trop gros pour son crâne oh [
Musique]
je n'essaie pas d'acquérir vos voix
en fait donc je ne le fais pas  Je veux dire que
d'une manière inappropriée, je n'ai tout simplement pas eu
le temps de le formuler
de la manière la plus élégante possible
[Musique]
Ma mère m'a sauvé la vie Mon père voulait m'avorter
Ma mère m'a sauvé la vie là
été pas de kanye west
parce que mon père était trop occupé, elle est venue chez
lui enceinte
et pendant un mois et deux mois et
trois mois,
nous avons parlé de sa sieste en ayant cet
enfant vous savez
qu'elle avait les pilules dans ses mains les
gens que nous ressentons
quand vous prenez  les pilules et si vous
les prenez c'est un enveloppement le bébé est parti
et j'ai appelé ma femme
et elle a dit que nous allions avoir ce bébé
j'ai dit que nous allions avoir cet enfant
je connais des gens de 50 ans qui
n'en avaient pas
des enfants qui n'ont pas eu cet enfant
qui a eu
le niveau de joie que j'ai ressenti en
ayant un enfant
mais même si ma femme devait divorcer
après ce discours,
elle a amené le nord dans le monde même
quand je ne le voulais pas,
elle s'est levée  et elle a protégé cet
enfant
j'ai presque tué ma fille l'avortement
devrait être légal mais l'option d'
augmentation maximale devrait être disponible pour
tous ceux qui ont un bébé
[Musique]
quand vous avez un orgasme et que vous êtes aussi un
cousin
et une soeur d'héroïne
donc fondamentalement certains le feraient  dire que
j'étais accro à une forme plus petite d'
héroïne
et que je vivrais dans ce manoir mick
dans cette communauté fermée avec mon maybach
et je conduirais à calabasas haut comme une
mère
[Musique]
quand harriet tubman
bien harriet tubman n'a jamais réellement libéré
les esclaves jésus  Si les esclaves sont allés travailler
pour tous les Blancs, nous partons
maintenant
[Musique]